[Music]
okay now I don't want to alarm anybody
in this room but it's just come to my
attention that the person to your right
is a liar
also the person to your left is a liar
also the person sitting in your very
seats is a liar we're all liars what I'm
gonna do today is I'm gonna show you
what the research says about why we're
all Liars how you can become a life
spotter and why you might want to go the
extra mile and go from life spotting to
truth seeking and ultimately to trust
building now speaking of trust ever
since I wrote this book live spotting no
one wants to meet me a person anymore no
no no no no they say it's okay we'll
e-mail you I can't even get a coffee
date at Starbucks my husband's like
honey Deception maybe you could have
focused on cooking have a French cooking
so before we get started what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna clarify my goal for you
which is not to teach a game of gotcha
ly spotters aren't those in nitpicky
kids those kids in the back of the room
that are shouting gotcha gotcha
your eyebrow twitched you flared your
nostril I watched that TV show lie to me
I know you're lying no lie spiders are
armed with scientific knowledge of how
to spot deception they use it to get to
the truth and they do what mature
leaders do every day they have difficult
conversations with difficult people
sometimes during very difficult times
and they start up that path by accepting
a core proposition and that proposition
is the following
lying is a cooperative act think about
it a lie has no power whatsoever by its
mere utterance its power emerges when
someone else agrees to believe the lie
so I know it may sound like tough love
but look if at some point you got lied
to
it's cuz you agreed to get lied to truth
number one about line lines a
cooperative act now not all lies are
harmful
sometimes we're willing participants in
deception for the sake of social dignity
maybe to keep a secret that should be
kept secret secret we say nice song
honey you don't look fat in that no or
we say favorite of the digerati you know
I just fished that email out of my spam
folder I'm so sorry but there are times
when we are unwilling participants in
deception and that can have dramatic
costs for us last year saw 997 billion
dollars in corporate fraud
alone in the United States that's an
eyelash under a trillion dollars that's
seven percent of revenues deception can
cost billions think Enron mad off the
mortgage crisis or in the case of double
agents and traitors like Robert Hansen
or Aldrich Ames lies can betray our
country they can compromise our security
they can undermine democracy that can
cause the deaths of those that defend us
deception is actually serious business
this conman henry Oberlander he was such
an effective con man British authorities
say he could have undermined the entire
banking system of the Western world and
you can't find this guy on Google you
can't find him anywhere he was
interviewed once and he said the
following he said look I've got one rule
and this was Henry's rule he said look
everyone is willing to give you
something they're ready to give you
something for whatever it is they're
hungry for and that's the crux of it if
you don't want to be deceived you have
to know what is it that you're hungry
for and we all kind of hate to admit it
you know we kind of wish we were better
husbands better wives smarter more
powerful taller richer the list goes on
lying as an attempt to bridge that gap
to connect our wishes and our fantasies
about who we wish we were how we wish we
could be with what we're really like and
boy are we willing to fill in those gaps
in our lives with lies on a given day
studies show that you may be lied to
anywhere from 10 to 200 times now
granted many of those are white lies
but in another study it showed that
strangers lied three times within the
first 10 minutes of meeting each other
now when we first hear this data we
recoil we can't believe how prevalent
lying is we're essentially against lying
but if you look more closely the plot
actually thickens we lie more to
strangers than we lie to co-workers
extroverts lie more than introverts men
lie eight times more about themselves
than they do other people women lie more
to protect other people if you're in an
average married couple you're gonna lie
to your spouse in 1 out of every 10
interactions now you may think that's
bad if you're unmarried that number
drops to 3 lying's complex it's woven
into the fabric of our daily and our
business lives we're deeply ambivalent
about the truth we parse it out on an
as-needed basis sometimes for very very
good reasons and other times just
because we don't understand the gaps in
our lives that's truth number two about
lying we're against lying but we're
covertly for it it ways that our society
has sanctioned for centuries and
centuries and centuries it's as old as
breathing it's part of our culture it's
part of our history think dante
shakespeare the bible news of the world
lying has evolutionary value to us as a
species researchers have long known that
the more intelligent the species that
larger the neocortex the more likely it
is to be deceptive now you might
remember cocoa does anybody here
remember Coco the gorilla who was taught
sign language Coco was taught to
communicate via sign language here's
Coco with her kitten it's her cute
little fluffy petkin Coco once blamed
her pet kitten for ripping a sink out of
the wall
we're we're hardwired to become leaders
of the pack it starts really really
early
how early well babies will fake a cry
pause wait to see who's coming and then
go right back to crying one-year-olds
learn concealment two-year-olds Bluff
five-year-olds lie outright they
manipulate via flattery nine-year-olds
Masters of the cover-up by the time you
enter college are gonna lie their mom
and 1 out of every 5 interactions by the
time we entered this work world and
we're breadwinners we enter a world that
is just cluttered with spam fake digital
friends partisan media ingenious
identity thieves world class Ponzi
schemers a deception epidemic in short
what one author calls a post truth
society it's been very confusing for a
long time now what do you do
well there steps we can take to navigate
our way through the morass trained
licensed were only fifty four percent
accurate why is it so easy to learn well
they're good liars and they're bad liars
they're no real original liars we all
make the same mistakes we all use the
same techniques so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna show you two patterns of
deception and then we're gonna look at
the hot spots and see if we can find
them ourselves we're gonna start with
speech I want you to listen to me I'm
gonna say this again I did not have
sexual relations with that woman miss
Lewinsky I never told anybody it's a lie
not a single time never these
allegations are false and I need to go
back to work for the American people
okay what were the tell-tale signs well
first we heard what's known as a non
contracted denial studies show that
people who are over determined in their
denial will resort to formal rather than
informal language we also heard
distancing language that woman
we know that Liars will unconsciously
distance themselves from their subject
using language as their tool now Phil
Clinton said well they tell you the
truth or Richard Nixon's favorite in all
candor he would have been a dead
giveaway for any life spotter that knows
the qualifying language as it's called
qualifying language like that
further discredits the subject now if he
had repeated the question in its
entirety or if he had peppered his
account with a little too much detail
and we're all really glad he didn't do
that he would have further discredited
himself Freud had it right Freud said
look there's much more to it than speech
no mortal can keep a secret if his lips
are silent he chatters with his
fingertips and we all do it no matter
how powerful you are we all chatter with
our fingertips I'm going to show you
Dominique strauss-kahn with Obama who's
chattering with his fingertips
now this brings us to our next pattern
which is body language with body
language here's what you got to do you
really got to just throw your
assumptions out the door let the science
temper your knowledge a little bit
because we think Liars fidget all the
time well guess what they're known to
freeze their upper bodies when they're
lying we think Liars won't look in the
eyes well guess what they look you in
the eyes a little too much just to
compensate for that myth we think warmth
and smiles convey honesty sincerity but
a trained licensed pot a fake smile a
mile away can you all spot the fake
smile here you can consciously contract
the muscles in your cheeks
but the real smiles in the eyes the
crow's feet of the eyes they cannot be
consciously contracted especially if you
overdid the Botox don't overdo the Botox
nobody will think you're honest and now
we're gonna look at the hot spots can
you tell what's happening in a
conversation can you start to find the
hot spots to see the discrepancies
between someone's words and someone's
actions now I know it seems really
obvious but when you're having a
conversation with someone that you
suspect of deception attitude is by far
the most overlooked but telling of
indicators an honest person is gonna be
cooperative they're gonna show they're
on your side they're gonna be
enthusiastic they're gonna be willing
and helpful in getting you to the truth
they're gonna be willing to brainstorm
named suspects provide details they're
gonna say hey maybe it was those guys in
payroll that forged those checks they're
gonna be infuriated if they sense their
wrongly accused throughout the entire
course of the interview not just in
flashes they'll be infuriated throughout
the entire course of the interview and
if you ask someone honest what should
happen whoever did forge those checks an
honest person is much more likely to
recommend strict rather than lenient
punishment
now let's say you're having that exact
same conversation with someone deceptive
that person may be withdrawn look down
lower their voice
pause be kind of herky-jerky ask a
deceptive person to tell their story
they're gonna pepper it with way too
much detail in all kinds of irrelevant
places and then they're gonna tell their
story in strict chronological order and
what a trained interrogator does is they
come in and in very subtle ways in over
the course of several hours they will
ask that person to tell their story
backwards and then they'll watch them
squirm and track which questions produce
the highest volume of deceptive tells
why do they do that well we all do the
same thing we rehearse our words but we
rarely rehearse our gestures we say yes
we shake our heads no we tell very
convincing stories we slightly shrug our
shoulders we commit terrible crimes and
we smile at the delight in getting away
with it
now that smile is known in the trade as
duping delight and we're gonna see that
in several videos moving forward but
we're gonna start for those of you that
don't know him this is presidential
candidate John Edwards who shocked
America by fathering a child out of
wedlock we're gonna see him talk about
getting a paternity test to see now if
you can spot him saying yes while
shaking his head no slightly shrugging
his shoulders lots of be happy to
participate in one I know that it's not
possible that this job could be mine
because of the timing of events so I
know it's not possible happy to take a
paternity test and would love to see it
are you going to do that soon is there
somebody then you can have only one side
how can only one side of the test but
I'm happy okay those head shakes are
much easier to spot once you know to
look for them now they're gonna be times
when someone makes one expression while
masking another that just kind of leaks
through in a flash murders are known to
leak sadness your new joint venture
partner might shake your hand celebrate
go out to dinner with you and then leak
an expression of anger and we're not all
going to become facial expression
experts overnight here but there's one I
can teach you that's very dangerous and
that's easy to learn and that's the
expression of contempt
now the anger you've got two people in
an even playing field it's still
somewhat of a healthy relationship but
when anger turns to contempt you've been
dismissed it's associated with moral
superiority and for that reasons it's
very very hard to recover from here's
what it looks like it's marked by one
lip corner pulled up and in it's the
only a symmetrical expression and in the
presence of contempt whether or not
deception follows and it doesn't always
follow look the other way go the other
direction reconsider the deal say no
thank you I'm not coming up for just one
more nightcap thank you
science has surfaced many many more
indicators we know for example we know
Liars will shift their blink rate point
their feet towards an exit
they will take barrier objects and put
them between themselves and the person
that's interviewing them they'll alter
their vocal tone often making them
making their vocal tone much lower now
here's the deal these behaviors are just
behaviors they're not proof of deception
they're red flags were human beings we
make deceptive flailing gestures all
over the place all day long they don't
mean anything in and of themselves but
when you see clusters of them that's
your signal look listen probe ask some
hard questions get out of that very
comfortable mode of knowing walk into
curiosity mode ask more questions have a
little dignity treat the person you're
talking to with rapport don't try to be
like those folks on Law & Order and
those other TV shows that pummel their
subjects into submission don't be too
aggressive it doesn't work now we've
talked a little bit about how to talk to
someone who's lying I'm gonna have a
spot a lie and as I promise we're now
gonna look at what the truth looks like
but I'm gonna show you two videos two
mothers one is lying one is telling the
truth and these were surfaced by
researcher David Matsumoto in California
and I think they're an excellent example
of what the truth looks like this mother
Diane downs
shot her kids at close range drove him
to the hospital while they bled all over
the car claimed a scratchy haired
stranger did it and you'll see when you
see the video she
can't even pretend to be an agonizing
mother what you want to look for here is
an incredible discrepancy between
horrific events that she describes and
her very very cool demeanor and if you
look closely you'll see duping delight
throughout this video but at night when
I close my eyes I can see Christie
reaching her hand out to me while I'm
driving and the blood just keep coming
out of her mouth and that maybe it'll
fade too with time but I don't think so
that fogs me the most
now I'm going to show you a video of an
actual grieving mother Erin Runyon
confronting her daughter's murder and
torture in court here you're gonna see
no false emotion just the authentic
expression of a mother's agony I wrote
this statement on the third anniversary
of the night you took my baby and you
hurt her and you crushed her she
terrified her until her heart stopped
and she fought and I know she fought you
I know she looked at you with those
amazing brown eyes and you still wanted
to kill her and I don't understand it
and I never will okay there's no
doubting the veracity of those emotions
now the technology around what the truth
looks like is progressing on the science
of it we know for example that we now
have specialized eye trackers infrared
brain scans MRIs that can decode the
signals that our bodies send out when
we're trying to be deceptive and these
technologies are going to be marketed to
all of us as panaceas for deceit and
they will prove incredibly useful
someday but you've got to ask yourself
in the meantime who do you want on your
side of the meeting someone who's
trained in getting to the truth or some
guys gonna drag a 400-pound
electroencephalogram through the door
lie spotters rely on human tools they
know as someone once said characters who
you are in the dark and what's kind of
interesting is that today we have so
little darkness our world is lit up 24
hours a day it's transparent with blogs
and social networks broadcasting the
buzz of a whole new generation of people
that have made a choice to live their
lives in public it's a much more noisy
world so one challenge we have is to
remember over sharing that's not honesty
our manic tweeting and texting can blind
us to the fact that the subtleties of
human decency character integrity that's
still it matters that's always what's
going to matter
so in this much noisier world it might
make sense for us to be just a little
bit more explicit about our moral code
when you combine the science of
recognizing deception with the art of
looking listening you exempt yourself
from collaborating in a lie you start up
that path of being just a little bit
more explicit because you signal to
everyone around you you say hey my world
our world it's going to be an honest one
my world is going to be one where truth
is strengthened and false it is
recognized and marginalized and when you
do that the ground around you starts to
shift just a little bit and that's the
truth
[Applause]
[Music]
you